while you were on set you had a you had
a birthday yes I turned 50 no nothing
there so much but I do confess I asked
their clothes off the password to it you
know I have to confess because the girls
I do pull my hair you see it like here's
a little bit fooling me a headache but I
am enduring it for you probably could
deliver in a couple of years no no the
pooling nobody don't mean yeah thank you
no it was like you seem good anyway they
celebrated Aurora mariachi band and it
was I was really moved I came to work
about to work on my 50th birthday and
but when I arrived which I'm sorry
all of them unhappy or have to work
tonight revival rock and then of course
I opened the car door and there's this
mariachi and I cried I was amazing and
then they told me that the producer when
Miguel proposed a mariachi she said but
is that politically correct such a nice
ring a mariachi you're gonna think he's
racist yeah this is a so she was really
nervous so I made a joke occurrence I
need to talk to you I gotta say I'm
really grateful for their thought of
doing something on my birthday but
really yeah
he's having tacos for normally I give a
little races but then then I felt
[Music]